well while we are slowly continuing to
open here in southern nevada the need to
help people
is unfortunately still on the rise three
square food bank helps families and
as sally jaramillo found more and more
assistance is going to be needed as we
move toward the holidays
we provide them the food and they feed
directly the needy clients in our
community three square chief
operating officer larry scott says in
normal times
they would have 200 volunteers but due
to covet
the volunteers dwindled but not the
people in need
that was a big disruption to our
organization and then social distancing
caused us to have to go to a model of
drive through distributions
fast forward eight months and volunteers
are returning
knowing a lot of work has to be done the
data that we get from feeding america
before the pandemic let us know that we
had about 270 000 food insecure
individuals
in southern nevada the most recent
analytics tell us that that number is
closer to four hundred and fifty
thousand and with more amounts to feed
there is a cause the federal commodities
and the cares act has provided that
increased
need that we had three square is able to
determine
areas in the valley in most need 89106
is one of our highest
food insecurity might range as high as
12 000 people in one zip code
and 1500 in another if we want to look
for a
silver lining that exists with a
pandemic it's how the community has
reached out to us to be able to help
i'm not really worried about us
fulfilling
what we need to do we will be there for
the needy
sally garamillo 8 news now three square
also has a senior hunger program where
once a month seniors can get
picked up at their home to be taken to
one of their golden grocery pantries
so we have posted information about more
of those programs for you on our website
at 8newsnow.com
[Music]
your most accurate forecast now ahead we
have a 20